look i've i saw society break down in
the la riots
i was in los angeles with the army for
three weeks
and i also saw what happened in kosovo
and i know history none of this is a
surprise
tell us about uh how the la riots uh
kicked off and what was going on and why
were you down there well i was
uh i had gone out of the army and i had
sold all my guns
uh back in germany and i was in uh
living a mistake
well in retrospect i was living in
pasadena
and i joined went and joined the cal
national guard uh an infantry unit in
inglewood
which is uh it's a much nicer place than
it was back in
19 or 1992 and uh
the uh verdict came down from simi
valley where they acquitted the police
officers
that was so rodney king rodney king cops
get off yeah
and uh trouble started and i'm watching
the news and i
you know i'm new to the unit i call up
hey are we getting mobilized no of
course we're not getting mobilized i go
oh okay i know enough about the army to
pack
but i didn't have a gun so i'm like damn
okay
so i pack like an hour later yeah we're
mobilizing get down here so i gotta
drive
into south central okay no gun
and i have a chevy beretta not a beretta
pistol beretta car
and i drive up to this um uh
lapd roadblock a guy's got a uh
remington 870 shotgun he comes up to me
goes
what the hell are you doing here i go i
i gotta go to my army unit
he goes what he got a gun i said no he
said you still want to go in there i
said not really but i don't have a
choice he goes drive real fast
stuff's burning and stuff so boom i
drive in
and all most of my guys were from south
central
and they were all packed the army
in its finish they had a bunch of guns
right they had their own were they like
here you go buddy
uh well i believe me there i saw more
guns there than i'd ever seen in my life
uh all the military ammo had been
centralized at one location because it's
easier to count that way
a little harder to distribute but uh
everybody had guns
uh and uh you know we we went out on the
street very soon thereafter
and uh three weeks and it was uh it was
very ugly and i was in the battalion
commander's vehicle and we drove around
and
it was uh it was an ugly scene but there
but
there there was no law and order
i mean all the things we take for
granted we're just completely gone
things were burning people are scared
yeah the koreans on the roofs with their
rifles
uh they knew how to regulate now now
we're hearing because uh that there's
this like
rise in hate crimes against asians
asians are getting armed like crazy
good i support every american owning
that's the that's the legend of the the
roof koreans
yeah in the la riots did you see any of
that stuff
i don't remember i don't think i was in
korea today right i lived in koreatown
briefly it's crazy
crazy to imagine this like i would go
for frozen yogurt i couldn't imagine
someone shooting from the remember all
these guys were
rock soldiers right they're republic of
korea
everybody everybody in korea does a tour
in the military
so these and they're tough dudes i mean
they're they're a real military
these flight games you've seen these
photos the dude's got got a cigarette
and he's holding the rifle oh yeah
yeah uh he had a uh a me 14 and a
cigarette just smiling
and it's like these and they all had
military training and they did not play
nope and uh people were like okay maybe
we don't try and knock off this liquor
store
frankly i think every american look if
you are a adult healthy
american citizen who is inclined to do
it because i understand are people who
have moral
issues about weapons and violence i
don't in that
way i'm not a i'm not a pacifist but if
you do i
give you a pass i think everybody else
uh needs to have uh
uh firearms and sufficient training to
be able to defend themselves their
family their community and their
constitution
yeah this is a i also think everybody
ought to know basic medical stuff how do
you stop the bleeding how do you do cpr
how do you do a heimlich maneuver i
think look as citizens we just
we don't even we we seem to think
everything can be outsourced bro um we
have become jelly doughnuts
we we used to i
do does the average person know how to
do cpr does the average
person know how to tend to a bleed do a
tie a tourniquet no any kind of basic
survival
medical fighting in any combat like
i watch these videos of people getting
into fights and i'm like what is he
doing
like they're just like cartoon versions
of fighting because people don't know
the basics of defense of anything and
this is not about being aggressive and
going out and causing trouble
this is being able to do your duty as a
citizen
to have order and safety in society
if you go to a car wreck i carry i carry
a ready bag in my car right
so i got i got stuff i got tourniquet i
got uh
uh the the blood uh the uh
leading stop gauze stuff uh some israeli
packet
i mean if i have to do something look
i'm not s i'm not an emt
but you know if you've got a sucking
chest wound i'll probably be able to
keep you alive till the emts get you
there
do you know why you should carry around
a first aid kit
sometimes it rains we know it rains yes
sometimes this rain causes car crashes
yes
it actually rains quite a bit yes it
actually causes quite a bit of car
crashes yes
you never know when it's going to be you
your friend or someone you stumble upon
and you know i look at these disasters
we've seen just with the with the
weather in texas
and i'm wondering how many of these
people just had no idea because we are
so soft
yes that everything's taken care of for
us we have nothing to worry about
anymore
have you seen the movie wall-e the
little robot cleaning up the earth right
and the big fat humans are in those
floating chairs doing nothing and
they're confused
the guy thinks the book is called manuel
it says manual he can barely even read
it's idiocracy man we we we are
weakening ourselves to the point where
we will regret it because
we are in a golden age or we're coming
out of one yes where everything was
comfortable and we're wealthy and it's
just energy everywhere super cheap
we have we have the summation of human
knowledge in our pockets we argue with
strangers and look at cats on a moment's
notice
and for this we have distracted
ourselves to the point where a fire
could start in our homes which is fairly
common
and then people will freak out spin in
circles confused as to what to do
or my favorite one more thing in the
ferguson riots
i'm in the ferguson riots and i hear
gunshots
the first thing i do hit the deck i look
to my right my camera guy all right on
the ground and i'm like good man
and then i saw that video from cnn where
the woman is live
and they're asking what's going on your
gunshots and she goes oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh and she's just
wiggling her arms in the air like she
has no idea
i'm like lady get behind a building what
are you doing and then she runs into a
into a gangway between two buildings
and i'm like it is is remarkable they
send these people on the streets
i've watched so many journalists hear
gunshots go off and go
those gunshots and everyone's on the
ground and i'm like bro
at least you can say when in rome right
if you watch people hit the ground after
after a bang goes off
and you're not doing that maybe there's
something you need to understand about
what these people in the community
understand
well they probably know a little better
and i like the way that you mentioned
rome because you see any parallels and
it's not a perfect parallel
but romans were the height of uh
height of civilization and when they
were great
in the early uh in the uh republic
period in the uh
early uh empire you know it was regular
citizens who went out and made up their
army
it was affluent citizens you actually
had a property qualification
to become a soldier you were invested
in it and you would go out and you would
leave your farm and you would be gone
for 10 years campaigning against
you know hannibal or whoever and uh
yeah and there was greatness and then
that stopped and they started saying
well
maybe maybe you know flavius why should
i go
we'll just get uh you know hans from uh
across the rhine he'll come we'll pay
him a few uh
a few ducats and uh he'll uh he'll do
our fighting for us
and pretty soon there was you know
germanic uh
germanic empires yep and then when the
conflict actually comes
instead of being like spartans you know
like king leonidas
killing the messenger and kicking him
into the pit they became the flailing
ceiling
journalists going oh they're coming they
have spears what do we do
and almost quite literally when attila
came they they sent
basement like the the you know a roman
priest out with a bunch of gold to
talk him out of it which he managed to
do strangely well so so talking about
the law right it's like think about the
people there who just took
think about when the when everything
broke down who the people were who just
went and took whatever they wanted
those people understood survival and
when there was no rule of law they said
i don't care it's me or you
so they're going to go out and do
whatever they want yeah well it's
interesting i think if you look at a
city like los angeles
imagine the chinese take down our water
system
and our logistics system suddenly the
water
pumps stop the the uh uh
the the sewage system stops because they
go in and they they they wreck the
computer code and the logistics system
stops so you're getting no food
10 12 million people with nothing to
drink and nothing to eat and you know
what they're gonna do
oh my god they're gonna eat each other
yeah that's right
no i mean literally they will be
drinking drinking each other's blood in
three
four days it's
people don't get this man new york 2.5
million people on manhattan island
when when if the water shuts down and
it's and it's shut down
like there was a power outage when sandy
hit and things were very very disastrous
it was scary it wasn't as bad it was
only a couple weeks but i remember lines
out the door of the bodegas and they had
two big guys with like baseball bats
standing in front of the buildings
in front of these bodegas because there
was no electricity
it was all cash exchange everything that
was perishable perished
and so you had lukewarm water and
gatorades and things like that you could
buy
the dry goods you could buy or the
canned goods but imagine if it was
sustained for longer than that
um things would get very scary very
quickly
uh you know i still tend to keep my uh
my cars fueled yeah i mean if they start
it starts getting halfway to empty
i'm like i just did just yesterday it's
just you know
i remember the wildfires in california
which
we've had numerous stories of this i
commanded two battalions during the 2007
what happens if you live in these areas
and your your car is on
you know an eighth of a tank and a fire
breaks out yeah you die
you die that's why you keep your car
fueled that's why you keep your electric
car charged if you have an electric car
and and every this this stuff isn't
super hard
it's just not internalized
because we've never had to worry about
these
problems but the problems will come to
you eventually
uh and i think that's i think that's why
the covid thing is people's wood style i
think they are excited about it
i mean look they don't want 500 000
people to die
but you know it's kind of there's a
little risk not much i mean if you're
healthy you're
99.5 going to survive life's boring
lifespan
now it's exciting i've got to wear a
mask i remember going into trader joe's
and uh my beautiful wife was with me and
we're looking around at people taking
stuff off the shelves they're not going
crazy but they're
they're loading up and the shelves were
getting empty
and it was a little scary
no i i wasn't like terrified but it was
like okay you know intense
i'm intense other people but people were
excited about it
and they were they were actually
behaving very well and there were there
were a lot of good humor
but you know it's something different
it's something new i feel
i feel more alive when i was in the
riots when i was in the war even though
i
look i was so far in the rear after
fedex bullets to hit me i literally ran
a heavily armed car wash so i'm not
trying to come along as pete buddha
judge or dick blumenthal
or any of the war heroes but when you're
in
a situation like that when you're part
of this kind of
massive event that's historical and
there's this little element of danger in
it
it's exciting yep and you you remember
it
and it's i'm not gonna call it fun but
god i wouldn't have missed it for the
world that's what uh drives a lot of
journalism
you know the the reason i wanted to
travel around covering these stories was
to experience these major historical
moments
and i always tell people like look i've
been skateboarding my whole life i'm an
adrenaline junkie i used to jump off
buildings when i was like 16.
so you tell me i can go into a conflict
zone and it's meaningful work that's
important to a lot of people and you can
share their story and tell the world's
happening
and you're running full speed you're
like it's intense
it makes you feel like what you're doing
matters yes it gives you a a
a feeling of risk or danger so you get a
reward you know mental reward after
you've you've made it through these
things
and many of them i didn't go into war i
wasn't in anything like you were you
know you said you were the in the car
wash well i was in civil unrest and
civil conflict
granted a revolution here and there and
some pretty dangerous neighborhoods
i was in the favelas in brazil i had
some turkish anarchists hold them a
molotov cocktail to my face threaten me
but not in anything where it was like
enemy factions who would kidnap and
murder me it was mostly like i'd get
beat up and thrown out or whatever
but it was it's it's exhilarating yeah
and it's and i i think people
need something like that i think they
seek it i think they want it i think
there are a lot of people who don't want
this to end
because it also excuses a lot of things
if you if you're one of those depressos
i'm not staying at home because i can't
force myself to go out and socialize i'm
staying at home
because i've got to save lives it's an
excuse it's an
excuse and it empowers them and god and
you hear these people and all it is time
about the vaccines vaccines vaccines
okay i i had coveted i caught it working
for the uh president in nevada
um and uh uh
it was uh it was like a bad cold
not bad cold and okay cold in terms of
the severity of it in terms of severity
now there are other people who
who died from it and it could hurt
people and of course as soon as you get
it
right yeah i got covered oh i had this
friend whose friend was a 21 year old
triathlete and he got in two days later
he spontaneously combusted so i'll
clarify just for the the the youtube
people who are listening
you're talking about how it felt yes the
death rate and i'll clarify because
they just deleted one of crowder's
videos for this
the death rate is substantially worse
than a cold or the flu oh yeah no
but but they deleted experience of it
was no people die from this thing
there's
five hundred thousand people's
statistics have died from
it is a real thing it is it is also if
you're in good health you're
probably going to make it 99.95 for
people under 70. yeah and then when you
factor in 70 year olds it's 97.5
survival yeah so that that is uh so it's
something
it is it is it is something it's it's
definitely worse than the flu
yes primarily uh impacting seniors and
people with co-morbidities yes
but man do they love to censor anybody
the moment they step out of line on this
one
i'm just telling you what i i'm just
telling you my personal experience with
it
um and uh but i i think a lot of people
you were mentioning the vaccines in the
vaccine yeah
yeah i mean you know people people
talking about the vaccine all the time
okay and i've been told uh you know even
though i had it i should go get the
vaccine
so um people the problem the problem is
that fauci
has been telling people it doesn't
matter and that that well that's that
that seems to me to be super
wrong-headed
yeah if you actually want people to take
the vaccine
because it doesn't make any sense it's
either effective or it isn't
this what i've seen says it's effective
so why is he down
trump thinks it's effective but fauci is
telling people that oh we don't know so
you just might as well stay home lock
your door and you know
he could do a better job let's let's i
want to talk about the
the political conflict because you
mentioned that you know we're basically
talking about people are not prepared
for when things break down yes if if if
chaos erupted
you know you you were in the la riot i
mean you were in war i've seen my fair
share of riots
i'll tell you this look i was so far in
the back i had to watch flashes on the
horizon that's more than most people
have ever seen
look the last thing i want to do is come
across as mr mister
macho comeback again i ran a
decontamination platoon we did a very
good job
i was not a hero i didn't get shot at i
didn't shoot it thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time